y le pregunto Cuál es la importancia de
esta reunión y esta relación
francoalemana para Europa
angelado un placer estar hoy aquí para
hablar como francés y como europeo antes
de todo de esos tratados de hace 60 años
donde empezó a unir justamente nuestras
dos naciones esto ha tratado bilateral
que vemos que la amistad entre los dos
países sigue y se fortalece cada año
Aunque muchas veces se habla antes de la
pareja Franco alemana durante la época
de literaria Y eso bueno se acabó ahora
somos de nuevos amigos
ya no somos pareja bien cómo está
afectando esta serie de desacuerdos
entre ambos mandatarios al bloque
europeo y que se precisamente se busca
mejorar el día de hoy Bueno se está
mejorando vemos Que a nivel de política
de defensa Todavía falta el tema del
escudo europeo que ajusta a Alemania va
por su lado y del otro lado regresamos a
noviembre donde justamente se volvió a
retomar el tema del avión justamente
Franco alemán Bueno también va a estar
España participando que era un proyecto
del 2017 con el tema económico el precio
del gas que justamente unos querían
topes otros no el tema de los subsidios
hubo muchos roces es decir divergencias
pero parece que vamos por una
convergencia poco a poco ahorita Bueno y
sin embargo el presidente macrón no ha
podido encontrar en olafels el mismo
socio que tenía en Angela Merkel Por qué
no y se podría llegar a tener las
relaciones tan altas como las vimos hace
algunos años Sí porque vemos que ahora
cada uno habla de su lado que aún no
hace las cosas sin consultar al otro
antes realmente era una pareja como
decía y decir que como pareja hasta con
Ángela merker se hablaban se tomaba
decisiones buscaban justamente un
compromiso ahora cada uno hace de su
lado y después se reúnen Bueno ya
decidimos esto por ejemplo con el tema
del gas que es problemático para alemán
Alemania porque no quiere un tope con el
tema de los subsidios apoyos a las y a
las empresas Entonces no cada uno va por
su lado Entonces en este momento La idea
es ver que se puede hacer pero esta
reunión lo que vemos es una fortaleza
muy fuerte entre los dos parlamentos Eso
sí se notó en los discursos de ambos
representantes